salut c'est norman aujourd'hui je
réponds à vos questions sur twitter
j'espère qu'elles sont pertinentes
c'est parti je parie que je ne passerais
pas sur cette vidéo le cadeau le plus
surprenant venant d'un fan un jour lors
de l'un des spectacles une fille qui m'a
offert ce ce masque de moi même voilà
donc ça m'a fait faire plaisir mais je
vois pas trop à quoi peut me servir ce
masque à part me déguiser en moi même et
c'est normal non je déconne
norman teisseire nas et naturel bah non
c'est du maquillage d'accord ok c'est
quoi ses cernes on dirait je suis en
forme tu vraiment que je passe pour un
mec qui a bien dormi
norman comment fais tu pour avoir
toujours la classe comme ça au quotidien
mme atwood poste naturel dans la mer
c'est toi qui t'es poser ta propre
question là non
bah si c'est écrit j'aimerais savoir si
quand les gens te critiquer tu insultes
ça te fait quoi
évidemment ça me fait super plaisir
c'est la roma est norman va te faire
merci nique ta merde à temps à en boire
un café
est ce que tu pourrais dire un mot en
créole pour moi stp paniproblème
l'histoire les cheveux non ça c'est
marrant ça commence à faire les gamins
attend plus de 27 ans je suis pas là
pour faire des trucs de bébé de
maternelle question suivante
comptes tu faire compte pu faire d'autre
meetup à grenoble par exemple
bah écoutez ma pourquoi pas et j'ai
l'occasion de faire des meet up à amiens
à nantes à cannes à paris a donc pas
prochainement à grenoble
salut j'ai la coupe de jeanne d'arc
si tu étais un personnage de dessin
animé lequel serais tu pas moi
j'aimerais bien être trunk de dragon
ball z vraiment extrêmement stylet mais
j'ai très bien que c'est pas du tout ma
ressemblance première et beaucoup de
gens me disent que je ressemblais acide
de l'âge de glace beaucoup moins cool
java mais tu vas me faire les types de
personnes que tu détestes c'est à dire
qu'est ce que tu aimes pas chez les gens
j'aime pas trop les gens qui tombent et
parle papillonne des yeux il te parle
centre garder bonne question mais c'est
vrai que moi quand j'ai quand j'ai
commencé ce métier vous êtes tous les
gars préfères-tu tourner des vidéos ou
monter sur scène bah écoute les deux
autant j'aime autant faire les deux
j'espère que je pourrai longtemps
continué à pratiquer ses deux passions
entre guillemets penses tu avoir une
chance de gagner the voice
wtf alors j'ai pas trop comment je
pourrais gagner the voice puisque je ne
participe pas du tout à l'émission
adonneraient ta voiture me super bien
donc c'est très simple dans mon équipe
il décide de prendre patois mais norman
mec qui fait des vidéos sur youtube ça
n'a aucun rapport avec émission mais
c'est mon choix
voilà merci à tous qu'est ce que ça
donne toi avec une barbe ou moustache au
feutre archi morts ont déjà fait les
cheveux stop si tu devais faire une
émission de télé-réalité laquelle
choisirais tu n'as aucune je trouve que
chacune de ses émissions et de l'énorme
merde
vraiment je n'en ferai jamais de ma vie
as tu déjà eu un groupe de musique alors
rejoignez plusieurs je fais la musique
depuis longtemps bon là avec les vidéos
les spectacles j'ai un petit peu ralenti
mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu plusieurs
groupes de musique notamment un mou où
je chantais en effet je faisais de la
chanson française un petit peu comique
au cru que ça intéresse s'appelait
monsieur languirand je vous mets un
petit liart as-tu déjà subi un
traitement orthodontique or
j'aurais pas à dire ce mot porte on est
gêné oui j'ai déjà subi un traitement
orthodontique voici la preuve
ah oui c'est quand j'étais petit j'avais
les dents de l'âne de shrek
donc voilà donc maintenant j'ai pu et
dans de l'âne de shrek mais j'ai la
gueule de sid donc c'est pas plus mal
tu m'a repéré un flot ce qu'il fait là à
temps c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a
les cheveux de rick devoe kindle même si
henry l'a pas trop cette chevelure jeu
comme quoi je parle de rick j'ai
vraiment là j'ai vraiment la coupe de
trunks ça y est je suis en mode trunk je
prends une douche après avec une club
une douche et nicolas pas les deux en
même temps je peux pas aller acheter
baguettes de pain comme ça impossible si
je sors dans la rue ont bien à temps
qu'est ce que tu as la lavande super
beau gosse pose problème ça devrait pas
si tu veux alors que toutes les femmes
si facilement question suivante
veux tu m'épouser non giec
le truc car avec ce en quoi pourquoi as
tu oublié le verbe dans ton pseudo
twitter c'est que twitter tapas le la
possibilité de mettre trop de l'être
alors dans norman fait des vidéos j'ai
dû enlever un mot donc ça fait normal
des vidéos cette explication est
beaucoup trop sérieuse est un peu
chiante
alors on va passer à une autre question
s'il te restait plus qu'un mot à dire
dans ta vie quel serait-il
je pense que ça serait le mot sus aux
normes à nous est en sus
sus au port en sus tous où il raconte
sur scène en 2015 pour ton spectacle
et quand je vous mets mon planning voilà
je fais une tournée dans toute la france
au printemps dans plein de grandes
villes enfin dans plein de villes ne vit
pas forcément grande je vais partout et
puis après 35 dates complètes à paris il
reste quelques dernières places
disponibles
du 10 au 25 avril à bobino allait bien
des n'hésitez pas regardé le planning
est à venir me voir si vous avez envie
je suis hyper marrant c'est abusé voilà
ma vidéo est terminé merci de l'avoir
regardé n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
hama chaîne youtube
et moi je vais tout simplement aller me
faire reprise et les cheveux 1re freezer
un art freezer de cheveux
allez ciao bon médecin il un peu flou il
parle en baragouinant penderie qu'il est
vraiment sous les quoi j'entends dire
qu'il y en a marre de répéter la même
chose à chaque fois à chaque
consultation avant toute intervention de
la gorge de mon avis monsieur rajoute
même que le taureau par jour ne l'est
pas